welcome to hurry saw is the channel
where we discussed the latest tech news
and delve into newest tech products so
recently the rx 580 got to the lowest
price that has ever been in the last 12
months at 270 $9.99 but does it even
matter given how close the gtx 1100
series and AMD Navi is but before we get
into that make sure to hit that
subscribe button if you guys like to
stay updated with the latest tech news
related to gaming and pcs so as you guys
already know the RX 580 and the rx 500
series have been one of the most
affected cards from the GPU mining craze
the rx 500 series to be affected by the
GPU mining craze and practice still
remain inflated however unfortunately
for the past couple months the prices
have been getting better and the RX 580
like I already suggested is being
offered for the lowest price that has
been offered in the last 12 months while
at first it seemed like the prices would
never go down for the rx 580 because for
the first 10 months the rx 580 was just
completely stuck at $440 prices did
start to come down starting in around
May and he's been dropping around two
and a half dollars on average per day
since that if you guys are interested in
asked why the GPU price for dropping
it's just slow rate and make sure to
check out my dedicated video on that but
anyways as it stands right now the RX
580 does seem like it's going to hit
MSRP or at least at lowest I can go
given the current Ram pricing situation
so as it is clear over the past 12
months the rx 580 was not even a
consideration for most gamers
however the rx 580 is actually a really
good mid-level card and so should you
buy it now that pricing is getting a lot
better
the rx 580 delivers pretty much
identical performance with the GTX 1060
and it is the perfect 1080p 60 frames
per second card so how does two gtx 1060
and 580 compare well they're pretty much
identical and in some games the GTX 1060
is better and some games 2 RX 580 does
better it's really as simple as that
at the same time AMD just recently
announced that they were going to come
out with a new graphics card in every
single year and on top of that the GTX
1100 series has been anticipated for
many months now and expected to come out
very soon so should you wait for those
instead of buying the rx 580 right now
well first off let's start off by
talking about Navi
so as for Navi Navi is going to
implement next-generation memory so gdb
are six memory most likely and if the
performance will probably be on the
higher level of things however the
problem with Navi is that Navi will most
likely be a higher level of set of cards
like Vega was last year I'm not sure if
AMD is planning to have one series of
graphics cards with all the graphics are
part of it or if they're going to keep
it in two series like the arc series and
the Vega series right now if they do
decide to do that then it would be the
RX six in her series and Navi wouldn't
really affect the average gamer so
that's pretty much out of the
consideration at least for right now and
on top of this na'vi isn't even expected
until 2019 so there's still a lot of
time for that anyways so what about the
RX 680 should you wait for that well
there hasn't been any leaks or rumors or
anything about the RX 680 and also if
you look back at the RX 480 which is the
last generations flagship for the
mainstream platform RX 480 and RX 580
we're pretty much identical on the arcs
580 didn't really improve that much over
their 480 so that may be how the RX 680
will be as well
recently Andy suggested that they are
going to become more focused on gaming
oriented graphics cards instead of AI
and machine learning graphics cards so
that's a good sign for gamers but the
thing is it takes a while to develop new
gaming graphics cards and so as a result
I don't believe the effects of those
actions will be reflected as early as
the rx 680 I think that it'll take at
least until the arc 780 or maybe even at
680 but at that point this rx 680
wouldn't be coming out for a while
though so should you buy the rx 580 or
continue to wait well I don't think
there's anything coming out from AMD in
the imminent future that would really
make a difference however on the GTX
side of things
the 1100 series is expected to come out
really soon as
late summer or early fall of this year
so that may be worth considering waiting
for but even with the GTX 1100 series
the GTX 1160 out of that series
probably won't come out until the end of
this year or early 2019 so it is still
quite a wait so if you guys really need
a graphics card right now I recommend
that you just keep a close eye on the RX
580 and the GTX 1060 because the
performance is pretty much identical and
you buy whichever one is cheaper at the
time of buying however if you can wait
then I recommend that you guys wait for
the GTX 1160 but it is supposed to cost
the same amount that you're willing to
spend for the RX 580 or GTX 1060 right
now
however performance will be much better
and it should be around the performance
of the gtx 1070 actually a little bit
better finally the last option that I
would recommend is waiting until the GTX
1170 and love and 80 come out in like
August or October of this year and then
buy a gtx 1070 which will most likely be
heavily discounted because it is then
outdated that way you'd be getting the
performance of the gtx 1070 we're not
spending much more than what you're
willing to spend right now for the RX
580 so in my opinion those are the three
best options right now if you can wait
then simply just wait for the gtx 1160
and pick it up for a good price when it
comes out if you can't wait then just
keep a close eye on the gtx 1060 and RX
580 and find a good deal and try to get
it on a real a discounted price finally
if you can wait some time but not too
long then may be a good option would be
to wait for the gtx 1170 and 1180 to
come out and it's not just 1070 for a
really good price but that's pretty much
all I have for you guys this time so
what do you guys think about this do you
guys think is better to wait for the GTX
1160 and get that or what about the rx
600 series do you guys think that
that'll be a big improvement over the
500 series make sure to comment down
below what you guys think because I do
read all my comments I'm curious as to
what you guys think so make sure to post
your thoughts also if you guys like this
video then make sure to drop a like and
hit that subscribe button if you guys
like to see more videos just like this
one but until next time bye